how you feeling I feel great yeah yeah I
feel really privileged to be here I feel
honored to get to be by this guy I get
to be with you this is the first time
never it's great and I've always snuck
off the Palm Springs and had a great fun
time this is a fun it's got energy some
of these things don't this has energy
well I think it's because it's the first
one it kind of kicks off award season
it's not televised you can just kick
back and have a great time and whatnot I
mean you you talk so glowingly and
lovingly about this role still to this
day is this still here with you 100
never get rid of I don't think it'll
ever go away yeah because in so many it
wasn't just any one thing it was the
experience that we had our friendship it
was the life experience it was the
amount of time it was you know I have to
tell you this do you know what
um on the film usually a baby is born
some of the keys had not one baby yeah
are you ready for a long award season
yeah I mean people have prepared me yeah
for the uh
yeah
they prepared you for it
yes uh yeah yeah I mean people have I've
talked to a lot of people about what
this experience is like and they've kind
of prepped me for the energy that you
need now you did give me a little inside
you took a little vacation you look very
tan so you look like yes that Mexican
son I was down in Cabo it was uh it felt
very nice to be down there now I will
have to say I'll be remiss because I did
see some photos that made it look like
you're a very good photographer are you
a good photographer wait a second
I don't know the photos you're referring
to I do like to take pictures okay yeah
okay
you know what so on the side he started
taking shooting on that context actually
at the contacts and I had to like yeah
and we're liking nuts Mandy Walker my DP
who is a like a nut and who was at the
original workshop with Austin I mean
she's with me every step of the way but
we start taking pictures and then Austin
starts doing it and we know immediately
he's got an eye yeah I I have some of my
treasured photos are actually on set
between takes I would pull out a film
camera and I'd take some pictures
you know you never have any privacy so
of course there were photos of you
taking photos
yes you know I was wondering because we
were in the pool and I saw a hang glider
going by and I thought I wonder if
that's a Paparazzi it must have been
that person I think it was I think it
was but you have now been being the
internet's best boyfriend is that right
we're getting the best angles baby you
were getting the best angles ever
foreign